air force making some big changes to its
physical
fitness test the standard one used to
include push-ups sit-ups and running a
mile and a half
but soon candidates will have options
instead of running
they can walk push-ups can be replaced
with
holding themselves up in that position
and doing
alternate arm lifts and they can do
planks
instead of sit-ups dana the military
commanders in china are laughing at us
well i can imagine that the recruitment
did the show on newsroom and he said
that it's not about
looking good it's about being physically
fit to the point that you will need
to be able to either run if you need to
or he said he would not have survived
if he had not been physically fit when
he sacrificed both of his legs in that
bomb blast
so he said that for him that was a
matter of his survival and
that's why the physical fitness test is
important it's not just about being able
to fit into your genes
jesse you're going to do the plank or
are you going to do the
i'm surprisingly strong at planking i
had to do it when i hurt my back so i
can plank for about two minutes
very good form but this is not what this
is about walk the plank that's what i'd
like to see you do right now you're
about to do it i heard you're talking
um i do see the irony in an overpaid
middle-aged man who talks for a living
on his keister criticizing the armed
forces for their strength and
conditioning requirements
so i just want to say thank you to the
men and women first
for protecting us with that said
now it gets dark very good no i'm
kidding they need to it's the air force
right so they need to fly fast not run
fast and i agree with dana
they got to get recruits maybe they have
to lower some standards that is fine
but it does strike me as a little weak
that this is happening
and i feel like i should not say much
else because i don't want to say
anything that might get me into any
trouble
especially before the holiday weekend
right because then the next day when i'm
not
rearranged i'm not saying boo about the
air force the thunderbirds harold took
me up
and i have pulled 9gs and i have never
been
more sick in my entire life i was sick
for like 12 hours i was actually laying
on the tarmac
taking a nap in the sun
your first question to dana said that
the generals in china and russia and
north korea
have to be smiling that that we would
even be considering something
like this we're the united states of
america
we have the greatest fighting force in
the world
and i don't know how this reconciled
with that i get
recruiting people but this reminds a
little bit of our first story uh
you got to toughen up a bit here i mean
we we're the u.s and
if if we don't have these standards
we're going to go to krispy kreme policy
who went public today
versus a fitness policy then we're going
to we're going to suffer the
consequences so i hope they revisit this
well here's the deal if they like got on
the phone with the other countries and
they all agreed to lower the standards
yeah it's like look you know what we are
our country's getting really fat it's
all those carbs
and video games and and like right
putin's going same here
we've got the same we've seen you guys
too yeah it's like why don't we all
disagree
but you gotta you have to wonder in the
future how important is physical stamina
i get what joey's talking about
if you're in a tactical unit like if
you're in the seals right
you got to be fit like me but if you're
like if you are a pilot you could
probably be like jessie which is you
know out of shape
yes just because you're tall and you can
hide your fat but i think
think about like like are we we have to
are we
going to have the same kind of wars that
we've we were
used to seeing when we were growing up
now that you have drones
and maybe you have like specialized
groups like seals who just
we go in and we we do these what do you
call pinprick attacks
and and and is it gonna i mean do you i
i can't
for infantry this is just for these
people this is the thing though i
imagine that
are we past that at this point where
we're gonna be using
robotic devices if canada catches like a
bad idea and starts coming south we're
going to need infantry on the canadian
border
i think they should actually consider
just having everybody do like 30 minutes
intervals and arms with cody rigsby on
teletime and see how they do
and that could be the test but look at
what they want to change a mile and a
half run what were the things
this is not a long shuttle run shuttle
runs are hard though
is that just sprinting back and forth
don't you remember the erasers the
shuttle runs
with the erasers in school am i that old
i'm sorry i remember what were they
doing with the erasers
you run you have to move erasers you run
you want me to
show you yeah like all the stuff yeah
yeah right like
i mean and what's with the push-up it's
not all the way down you have to just
like lift your arms
yeah no you do like yeah those are hard
yesterday on the show we watched
chuck grassley do 20 guys 87 years old
he did 20-plus push-ups yeah
and we're telling you you're telling me
our air force can't do tremendously and
also the
problem with the air force is the reason
why american airlines is having such a
hard time
is that that's where you get your pilots
and there's a pilot shortage because
they're not coming out of the air force
well they don't want to work for
american ah
how un-american but i went to so uh late
fabin and jenna lee got married and leif
was retiring from the navy seals and so
all of his
seal team members with the wedding and
except for jocko willink who looked like
he was
cast as a navy seal all of them were
super
skinny and you had no idea and it's
because they have to be able
to do a dead man carry out of battle
they were hiding their fat they were
tall and skinny and hiding their back
apparently that's what it is you have to
be able to pick up another person
and carry them i picked up gut filled
pretty easily
i've been i've been carrying this show
forever
count it yes you have on that note
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else